in this video we'll define something
called the cost function this will let
us figure out how to fit the best
possible straight line to our data in
linear regression we have a training set
like that shown here remember our
notation M was the number of training
examples
so maybe M equals 47 and the form of our
hypothesis which we use to make
predictions is this linear function to
introduce a little bit more terminology
these theta 0 and theta 1 write these
theta eyes are what I call the
parameters of the model and what we're
going to do in this video is talk about
how to go about choosing these two
parameter values theta 0 and theta 1
with different choices of the parameters
theta 0 and theta 1 we get different
hypotheses different hypothesis
functions I know some of you will
probably be already familiar with what
I'm going to do on the slide but just a
review here are a few examples if theta
0 is 1 point 5 and theta 1 is 0 then the
hypothesis function will look like this
and because your hypothesis function
will be H of x equals 1 point 5 plus 0
times X which is this constant value
function there's just fat at 1.5 if
theta 0 equals 0 theta 1 equals 0.5 then
the hypotheses will look like this and
it should pass through this point to one
since you now have H of X really H sub
substrate theta of X but sometimes out
well I'll just omit theta for gravity so
H of X would be equal to just 0.5 times
X which looks like that
and finally if theta is equals 1 and
theta 1 equals 0.5 then we end up with a
hypothesis that looks like this let's
see I should pass through the 2 to point
like so and this is my
you H of X on my new subscript theta of
X all right where you remember I said
that this is H subscript theta of X but
as a shorthand sometimes I'll just write
this as H of X in linear regression we
have a training set like maybe the one I
plotted here what we want to do is come
up with values for the parameters theta
zero and theta one so then the straight
line we get all of this corresponds to a
straight line that somehow fits the data
well maybe that line over there so how
do we come up with you know values theta
0 theta 1 that corresponds to a good fit
to the data the idea is we're going to
choose our parameters theta 0 theta 1 so
that H of X meaning the value we predict
on implies X that this is at least close
to the values Y for the examples in our
training set for our training examples
so in our training set we're given a
number of examples where we know X
decides the house and we know the actual
price that was so for so let's try to
choose values to the parameters so that
at least in the training set given the
XS in the training set we make
reasonably accurate predictions for the
Y values let's formalize this sin linear
regression what we're going to do is I'm
going to want to solve a minimization
problem so the write minimize over
theta0 theta1 and I wanted this
to be small right I want the difference
between H of x and y to be small and one
thing I might do is try to minimize the
squared difference between the output of
my hypothesis and the actual price of a
house okay so let's throw in some
details you remember that I was using
the notation x I comma Y I to represent
the I've training example so what I want
really is to sum over my training set
sum from I equals 1 to M of the squared
difference between this is the
prediction of my hypothesis when it is
input the size of house number I right -
the actual price that house number I was
so full and I want to minimize the sum
over my training set sum from I equals 1
through m of the difference of the
squared error squared difference between
the predicted price of the house and the
price that it was actually so for and
just remind you of your notation M here
was the size of my training set right so
little m there is the my number of
training examples that hash sign is the
abbreviation for number of training
examples okay and to make some of our
later map a little bit easier I'm going
to actually look at you know 1 over m
times AB so we'll try to minimize my
average ever visually minimize 1 over 2m
the putting the to the constant you know
1/2 in front it just makes some of the
math mo bit easier so minimizing 1/2 of
something right should give you the same
values for the parameters theta 0 and
theta 1 as minimizing that function and
just make sure this this this equation
is clear write this expression in here
take subscript theta of X this is my
this is our usual write that is equal to
this
plus beta 1 X I and this notation
minimize over theta0 and theta1 this
means you'll find me the values of theta
0 and theta 1 that causes this
expression to be minimized and this
expression depends on theta 0 and theta
1 okay so just to recap we're posing
this problem as find me the values of
theta 0 and theta one so that the
average already 1 over 2m times the sum
of squared errors between my predictions
on the training set minus the actual
values the houses on the training set is
minimized so this is going to be my
overall objective function for linear
regression and just to rewrite this out
a little bit more cleanly
what I'm going to do is by convention we
usually define a cost function which is
going to be exactly this that formula
that I have up here and what I want to
do is minimize over theta0 and theta1 my
function J of theta 0 comma theta 1
where just read this out this is my cost
function
so this cost function is also called the
squared error function sometimes called
the squared error cost function and it
turns out that why do we take the
squares of the errors it turns out that
the squared error cost function is a
reasonable choice and will work well for
most problems for most regression
problems there are other cost functions
that will work pretty well but the
squared error cost function is probably
the most commonly used one for
regression problems layton's is also
talked about alternative cost functions
as well but this this choice that we
just had should be a pretty reasonable
thing to try for most linear regression
problems okay so that's the cost
function so far we've just seen a
mathematical definition of you know this
cost function and in case this this
function j of theta0 theta1 in case this
function seems a little bit abstract and
you still don't have a good sense of
what is doing in the next video in the
next couple of videos much going to go a
little bit deeper into what the cost
function J is doing and trying to give
you better intuition about what is
computing and why we want to use it